And all these things that we talked about,
this,
this word meaning that we used earlier
that we all understand that account
define is that a emergent
property that that has to emerge.
If you've got something that's intelligent
enough to replicate itself and Lavan
drives, you said be the,
I don't know the answer,
but it is worth considering
that this thing, this what we,
emotion meaning love and fear and all
those things are just the things that
happen when you are intelligent.
Right? I don't know the answer to that,
but it could possibly be and does
consciousness have to have a local origin?
Like it doesn't have to come from a thing.
Like if you think about cellular
communication, the, if you send me,
if you're in England and you send me a
video from your phone and it reaches my
phone,
it's getting to me through space.
It's going through the sky.
It's like literally from a device not
connected by any wires or anything.
It's coming to me.
If,
if there's a possibility to create some
sort of global intelligence through
electronics, that's nonlocal. If one
piece of it falls off this the same,
is it just repairs itself
or figures itself out?
But it's the same consciousness existing
on a global scale through some sort of
an electronic network that instead
of the idea that you and I have,
that Brian and Joe are,
you have your mind,
I have my mind and we
exist as intelligent,
being separate from each other,
but instead of that,
that all of it is connected and that all
of it is something that we can't even
conceive of because our brains are
too crude. Like trying to explain to,
you know, Australia pithy kiss
what a satellite is. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I mean, I, yes, I mean if you
think of our brains, they are ultimately,
what are they? They're just a distributed
network of cells connected by neurons.
And I mean,
they're very complicated,
but they are a colony of things that
are autonomous in a sense and the
communicating with each
other. So, yeah, I don't,
I don't see why you can't scale
that up in principle. I mean,
I should just add the caveat
is always that we don't know
about this. Yeah, it is.
It's just not understood.
Well,
I think there's something
weird has physical though.
I'm damn sure it's physical.
I'm damn sure that there's nothing
going on in my head other than what is
allowed by the laws of nature as we
understand them. So eliminating show,
you mean the idea of a soul being some
sort of a divine thing that's inside the
housing of the body? Yeah, I mean,
I, I would say we can rule that.
I actually, I've argued in the
past, how do you rule it out?
I've argued we can rule that out
in the following manner. So, so,
so here's my arm, right? So it's made of
electrons and protons and neutrons. And,
uh, if I, if I have a soul in there,
something that we don't understand,
but it's a different kind
of energy or whatever it is
we don't have in physics at the moment,
it interacts with matter because I'm
moving my hand around. So whatever it is,
it's something that interacts
very strongly with matter.
But if you look at the history of
particle physics in particular,
which is the study of matter,
we spend,
we spent decades making high precision
measurements of how massive behaves and
interacts and we look for, for
example, for a fifth force of nature.
So we know for forces the gravity,
the two nuclear forces called the
weak and strong nuclear forces and
electromagnetism and
that's what we know exist.
And we look for another one with ultra
high precision and we don't see any
evidence of it.
So I would claim that we know how
matter interacts at these energies.
So room temperature.
Now these Ngo,
we know how matter interacts
very precisely and so if
you want to suggest the
something else that interacts
with matter strongly,
then I would say that it's ruled out.
I would go as far as say it's,
he'd ruled out by experiment or at least
he sees extremely subtle and you would
have to jump through a lot of hoops to
come up with a theory of some stuff that
we wouldn't have seen when we've observed
how matter interacts that is present
in our bodies.
And presumably we believe in the soul.
You want it to exist outside.
When you die,
you still want the thing to be there and
you might believe in ghosts and things
like that. We look at
ghosts. I mean it's, uh,
it is something that carries the imprint
of you. Presumably it looks like you,
right? So that means that it interacts
strongly with the matter that is you,
because it carries a pattern.
If it carries a pattern
that carries information,
if he carries information,
there has to be an energy source that
allows the information to be assisting the
pattern to persist and so on.
So again, you end up with a,
a theory that is postulating,
something interacts with light.
Because if you think a ghost is the soul,
then it's something that
people see sometimes.
So that means interacts with light.
But we know how light interacts and we
ruled out anything but the most subtle,
uh, further interaction that we
haven't seen. So I would, I claim it,
I started off as a joke. This, actually,
I wrote it in an infinite monkey
cage book, this radio show that I do,
but he ended up, when I'd written it down,
I thought actually that it makes sense.
And I read some news similar actually,
I think, um, Sean Carroll, he,
I don't know if you've had
Sean on the shareable times.
He's said something in the same,
I think in the book that
he wrote the big picture.
I think he has a similar argument
actually. So it's occurred to him as well,
is roughly the same argument.
So if you,
so this energy that's interacting with
matter, even if you are not moving at all,
if you're just thinking it's interacting
with the matter that encompasses your
mind or your brain or your
nerves or your neurons,
it's something in there that's
interacting with matter,
whether you like it or not.
So even just a simple thought process
or a dream is still something it's
interacting with Matt. Yeah. Well
obviously cause it, you know, you,
it's your will isn't it in that sense
when you move, it's presumably, right.
So you can, even, if you're not
moving the idea, like the, you're,
you're saying you're like your body's
interacted with matter as you're moving
your arm.
But even if you're not moving,
if you're just thinking and
you're completely still,
which is not totally possible because
your heart's beating and your breathing
and all that stuff.
But if somehow or another you were
able to isolate just the thought,
the thoughts themselves are still
interacting with matter because they're
interacting with the brain itself.
Yeah. So there's something in there.
There's something that interacts with
the physical structure of your body.
And, and, and I would
say there isn't that we,
so that's
the woo woo version is that
the brain itself and the body,
the physical. So this,
this, this spiritual self,
you are merely an antenna
that's tuning in to the, the,
the great consciousness of the universe.
But why?
But then you have to answer what we know,
what we're made of. So we know how those
particles behave and interact. Right. So,
so why did the particles not,
uh,
in any way interact with that
stuff? Because we interact.
We don't if that's true,
we don't only just interact with it,
so we interact extremely strongly with it.
We're interacting with it now.
Every movement I make is the
interaction between that.
Every man's where you have,
yeah. Yes. What? Everything.
If I moved my fingers or I,
everything that I'm doing is an
interaction between that stuff in me.
So it's a very strong
interaction with matter,
but we don't see it in all our
precision measurement. Well,
that's the answer for that.
The answer is because it's not there.
The answer's Jesus and a,
you can't measure God.
That may be an answer, but the point
is, as we talked about earlier,
with absolute space, yeah, you
can't measure it. It's not there.
Right.
It's but for, for whatever
reason, for people,
there is some incredible motivation to
find a divine something or another that's
there's something greater than this
physical being that there's something.
What do you think that is? Like
what is that compulsion? It we,
we've already talked a bit about it.
I think it goes to the,
the heart of this question
of what it means to be human.
So I would say that being human,
the answer right to the, I don't
know the answer to the meaning of it,
but the answer would be,
uh,
we are small finite beings,
right?
Which are just clusters of atoms
as we said before, the very rare,
but we understand roughly how they,
how they came to be and we
have a limited amount of time,
not actually unfortunately,
but because of the laws of nature,
the laws of nature for bidders
to be immortal, that they, they,
they in mortalities ruled
out by the laws of physics.
But also actually what
was interesting about,
if you look at the basic physics of the
universe going from the big bangs where
we are today,
then the physics is driven by the fact
that the universe began in an extremely
old olded state because it was a very
highly ordered system and it is tending
towards a more disordered
system or the moments.
And that's called the second
law of thermodynamics.
And it's that basic common sense
thing that things go to shit.
Basically it's the second law of
thermodynamics. What we strongly suspect,
and I would say no,
uh,
is that in that process of
going from order to disorder,
complexity emerges naturally
for a brief period of time.
So it's a natural part of the evolution
of the universe that you get appeared in
time when there's
complexity in the universe.
So Stars and planets and galaxies
and life and civilizations,
but they are, they exist because
the universe is decaying,
not in spite of the fact that
the universe is decaying.
So our existence in that sort of
picture is necessarily finite,
the necessarily time limited.
And it is a remarkable thing that that
complexity has got so far that there are
things in the universe that can
think and feel and explore it.
And I think that is the answer. If you
want an answer to the meaning of it all,
it's that,
that you are part of the universe because
of the way the laws of nature work.
You are allowed to exist, but you're
allowed to exist for a temporary of,
for a small amount of time in it,
possibly infinite universe.